[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat de France 24
leur rencontre était très attendues pour
son premier déplacement hors de Chine
depuis deux ans depuis le début de la
crise du covid le président chinois Gigi
ping c'est entretenu avec Vladimir
Poutine le président russe ça s'est
passé à samarcan dans l'Ouzbékistan en
mars dans sommet de l'OCS l'organisation
de la coopération de Shanghai une
organisation qui regroupe la Russie la
Chine quatre axes républiques
soviétiques d'Asie centrale ainsi que
l'Inde le Pakistan et l'Iran les deux
hommes s'étaient vu la dernière fois aux
Jeux olympiques de Pékin juste avant le
début de la guerre en Ukraine à
l'occasion de ces retrouvailles tout
ailleurs tout à l'heure Vladimir Poutine
et Gigi ont affiché leur unité face aux
Occidentaux alors en quoi la guerre en
Ukraine a renforcé les liens entre
Moscou et Pékin quels sont leurs
intérêts communs cette relation a-t-elle
des limites résistera-t-elle au revers
de l'armée russe sur le terrain en quoi
cet axe Moscou Pékin inquiète les
chancellerie occidentales on va en
débattre avec nos invités ce soir
Pierre-Antoine Denet journaliste auteur
de Chine le grand prédateur un défi pour
la planète et de le dossier chinois
portrait d'un pays au bord de l'abîme
bonsoir Pierre-Antoine de neige merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
également à mes côtés Sylvie Berman
diplomate ancienne ambassadrice en
Russie en Chine mais aussi au
Royaume-Uni bonsoir et puis Adrien
desuins rédacteur à la revue conflit
auteur de la France atlantiste ou le
naufrage de la diplomatie aux éditions
du Cerf et avec nous également par Skype
Oleg copsaf professeur associé
d'histoire et géographie politique à
l'américaine University of Paris bonsoir
alors j'aimerais qu'on parte d'abord à
Shanghai retrouvé look qui est là notre
correspondante elle va revenir sur les
instants forts de cette journée
a d'abord salué Vladimir Poutine comme
son vieil ami mais il ne lui a pas donné
plus de gages sur l'Ukraine or la guerre
en Ukraine c'est le sujet sur lequel le
numéro un chinois était attendu mais
elle n'est même pas mentionnée dans le
compte-rendu de Pékin c'est du côté du
Kremlin qu'on apprend que Vladimir
Poutine se félicite de la position
équilibrée de la Chine sur le crâne et
qu'il dit prendre en compte les
inquiétudes chinoises à ce sujet le
dirigeant russe a aussi condamné les
provocations américaines dans le détroit
Taïwan une zone de tension
sino-américaine et dénoncer les
tentatives de créer un monde unipolaire
en ligne de mire de ces éléments de
langage les États-Unis c'est là que les
propagandes chinoises et russes se
rejoignent si Jean Ping de son côté
s'est dit prêt à soutenir la Russie dans
ses intérêts fondamentaux et à renforcer
la coopération notamment en matière de
commerce ou d'agriculture les liens
économiques c'est le ciment de la
relation entre Moscou et Pékin en
particulier sur l'énergie avec
l'augmentation des importations
chinoises de pétrole et de gaz russe
d'ailleurs après leur rencontre
bilatérale les deux dirigeants se sont
entretenus avec le président mongol pour
discuter de la construction de nouveaux
gazoducs de nouveaux oléoducs entre la
Russie et la Chine
et on va les écouter tout de suite
Vladimir Poutine et Gigi
les tentatives de créer un monde
unipolaire ont récemment pris une forme
absolument LED et sont totalement
inacceptables
nous apprécions grandement la position
équilibrée de nos amis chinois face à la
crise ukrainienne
face à un monde une époque et une
histoire constante évolution la Chine
est prête à faire des efforts avec la
Russie pour assumer le rôle des grandes
puissances et joue un rôle de guide
pour apporter stabilité énergie positive
dans un monde secoué par les troubles
sociaux
elle se fait clairement contre
l'Occident c'est le ciment aujourd'hui
de leur amitié
oui absolument après
là on sent bien dans les deux discours
des petites nuances parce que on voit le
président chinois qui qui incite surtout
sur la stabilité sur l'harmonie et un
peu dans le discours traditionnel
chinois autour de la souveraineté etc
qu'on retrouve notamment sur Taïwan et
le discours de Poutine est un peu plus
agressif quand même que celui du du
président chinois et pour le gagnant
disons de ce sommet ou de ces images
c'est plutôt Poutine parce que lui il a
vraiment intérêt et bien montrer qu'il
n'est pas isolé qu'il a toujours la
Chine derrière lui
ce qui est le cas depuis donc l'invasion
de l'Ukraine on rappelle que Poutine
avait mis dans la boucle chez inping de
cette affaire donc il garde il conserve
pour l'instant cette alliance chinoise
mais une alliance qui reste en retrait
qui reste sur les sujets économiques et
qui veut surtout pas être entraîné sur
le dossier ukrainien on va reparler tout
à l'heure justement Sylvie Berman
c'était important pour Vladimir Poutine
cette rencontre avec JJ ping de montrer
qu'il n'est pas isolé sur la scène
internationale lui qui fait l'objet de
sanctions depuis le début de ce conflit
en Ukraine oui bien sûr c'est important
alors cela dit la cette réunion de la
coopération de Shanghai et régulier ce
n'est pas une première ça fait une
vingtaine d'années que ça existe et ça
regroupe effectivement un certain nombre
de pays qui ne sont pas des démocraties
et les pays qui en sont membres que ce
soit l'un de le Pakistan les pays d'Asie
centrale et l'Iran n'ont pas voté pour
l'exclusion de la Russie aux Nations
Unies et c'est la moitié de la
population mondiale mais donc c'est
important d'avoir ce soutien là puis
d'avoir évidemment celui de Sidi inking
alors siding
il est embarrassé par cette guerre parce
que ce qui a été annoncé en février ça
devait être une opération militaire
spéciale qui serait réglée très très
rapidement beaucoup plus de temps de
prise on prend plus de temps que prévu
la Russie est d'ailleurs en situation
difficile mais les deux pays alors j'ai
plutôt le terme de partenariat que
d'alliance parce que la Chine ne veut
plus de d'alliance à la connu ça avec
l'Union soviétique elles sont détriment
et
c'est un partenariat qui est importante
parce que justement aux Nations Unies
Poutine ah alors sinon un soutien
explicite puisque la Chine a de bonnes
relations aussi avec l'Ukraine et comme
je disais sûrement n'apprécie pas
tellement cette intervention mais au
moins qu'il n'y ait pas de vote contre
la Russie et là il y a cette alliance
aussi bien au Conseil de sécurité qui
est totalement paralysé que à
l'Assemblée Générale donc effectivement
au moment
Poutine connaît de graves difficultés en
Ukraine on en parle bien d'être pour lui
de s'afficher avec de s'afficher avec
Céline pin avait dit à une époque
Poutine était son meilleur ami on va
écouter justement vous évoquez l'ONU on
va écouter l'ambassadeur chinois à l'ONU
en mars dernier après le début de la
guerre en Ukraine
le Kazakhstan est un pays majeur en Asie
centrale et à une influence importante
en Eurasie je tiens à réitérer le fait
que le gouvernement chinois attache une
grande importance à sa relation avec le
Kazakhstan quel que soit l'évolution de
la situation internationale la Chine
soutiendra toujours fermement le
Kazakhstan dans la sauvegarde de
l'indépendance nationale et de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale
le président chinois qui était en train
de s'exprimer on va écouter
l'ambassadeur chinois à l'ONU maintenant
qui s'exprimait en mars dernier après le
début la guerre en Ukraine pour vous
rappeler justement la position de la
Chine
le règlement total de la crise en
Ukraine requiert l’abandon de la
mentalité de guerre froide nous avons
toujours pensé que tous les pays ont une
souveraineté et que leur intégrité
territoriale doit être respectée
sur tout un partenariat avec la Russie
entre la Chine et la Russie c'est le cas
c'est plus un partenariat qu'une amitié
la Chine qui n'a jamais condamné cette
guerre en Ukraine
était demandeur c'est lui qui attendait
beaucoup de la Chine et on remarque bien
que le président sizing est resté
extrêmement prudent et cette prudence
s'explique
de divers points de vue d'abord
la Russie n'aura peut-être jamais d'aide
militaire chinoise parce que à mon sens
c'est la ligne rouge si la Chine
s'aventurer à livrer des armes et
assister la Russie dans sa guerre en
Ukraine cette ligne rouge serait
franchie et immédiatement la Chine
serait la cible de sanctions massive de
la part des États-Unis et qui serait
probablement suivi par un certain nombre
de ses alliés
et si tel était le cas ces sanctions
seraient extrêmement dures pour
l'économie chinoise alors que la Chine
traverse aujourd'hui des turbulences
considérables sur le plan économique
quel est aujourd'hui l'intérêt de la
Chine de soutenir Vladimir Poutine
et bien c'est dans la guerre on va dire
la compétition globale avec les
États-Unis et je dirais
notamment sur le dossier de Taïwan
évidemment Poutine a tout de suite
apporté un soutien très ferme évident à
l'action à la l'unité chinoise à travers
Taïwan et la et la République communiste
de Pékin donc je pense qu'il est là
l'intérêt principal après il y a aussi
une interdépendance énergétique
peut-être qui est plus à l'avantage à
dire de Poutine actuellement puisque il
a besoin d'écouler tous ces stocks de
gaz de pétrole de charbon et il a
considérablement augmenté ses
exportations valargies cette six
derniers mois donc voilà je crois que
l'intérêt de la Chine il est là
comme ça
elle avait surtout un intérêt pour le
président russe
je suis tout à fait d'accord tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
monsieur donnez
tout a été dit ou presque autour autour
de cette table
j'ai une chose quand même à rajouter qui
est importante alors Monsieur monsieur
monsieur monsieur monsieur
Denet également
monsieur données a souligné la prudence
et la mesure avec laquelle monsieur chez
Guillaume Ping a
accueilli monsieur Poutine
je vais dire une chose je vais vous
donner mon analyse de la situation la
Chine n'a qu'à attendre la Chine n'a
qu'à être patiente et voir ce qui se
passe
si Poutine a besoin de la Chine en
Ukraine pour le soutenir et s'il n'y a
pas trop de risques je rappelle encore
ce que vient de dire monsieur données
s'il n'y a pas trop de risques à aider
la Russie avec des armements avec
d'autres soutiens voir des soutiens
diplomatiques la Chine le fera mais ça
rendra la Russie dépendante de la Chine
et ça c'est dans tout c'est tout à fait
dans l'intérêt de la Chine la Russie au
cours de ce conflit pourrait devenir ce
que l'Angleterre finalement est devenu
par rapport aux États-Unis si le conflit
devient vraiment violent et et se
poursuit longtemps maintenant si les
choses vont mal nous avons un débat
juste ici sur le même sur le plateau
anglophone de France 24 il y a 48 heures
et
beaucoup des experts qui étaient là sur
le plateau
anticipe que les choses iront très mal
pour la Russie qui aura une retraite
qu'il y a que c'est il y en a qui
prédisent même qui que c'est le début de
la fin pour pour Poutine ce qui n'est
pas un peu cible mais dans ce cas la
Chine est également en excellente
position parce qu'elle pourra arbitrer
une solution une un traité d'armistice
voire de paix entre l'Occident et
l'Ukraine d'un côté et la Russie de
l'autre elle sera dans une excellente
position donc je crois que
la Chine est dans une situation
attentiste où elle a plutôt énormément
d'atouts qu'elle pourra mettre en oeuvre
selon l'évolution de la situation dans
un sens ou dans l'autre en tout cas la
Russie deviendra de plus en plus
dépendantes de la Chine la Chine elle
n'a qu'à attendre aujourd'hui
attendre attendre quoi parce qu'on dit
souvent que il y en affaiblissement de
la Russie pour que la Chine puisse
récupérer un certain nombre de de terre
ou
autre moi je crois pas tellement il y a
effectivement une asymétrie bien
évidente entre les deux pays d'ailleurs
souvent quand il y a des achats de gaz
ça se fait au terme chinois plus que au
terme russe donc c'est vrai qu'il y a ce
besoin mais en même temps ici a besoin
de la Chine mais la Chine a besoin de la
Russie aussi parce que aux Nations Unies
encore une fois les critiques
internationales les sanctions les vices
tous les deux et il y a un principe bien
connu qui est l'ennemi de mon ennemi et
mon ami et en fait le partenariat s'est
renforcé au cours de ces dernières
années depuis en fait les attaques de de
Trump contre la Chine aussi à ce
moment-là la Russie bon été sous SAN de
la part des États-Unis il y avait 1000
sanctions à peu près américaines contre
la Russie et du coup bah ils ont trouvé
un intérêt à être encore une fois
partenaire mais pas allié et ils ont
renforcé justement cette relation dans
le domaine commercial parce que le
commerce
a doublé parce que il y a une
coopération dans le domaine militaire
dans le domaine spatial je pense pas que
les Chinois vont fournir des armes parce
que comme monsieur denelle a dit
immédiatement
de la part des États-Unis et ça serait
très lourd pour l'économie chinoise et
elle observe la Chine ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à la suite de la guerre
d'agression en Ukraine et les sanctions
qui visent la Russie donc elle
en général la Chine est assez prudente
et elle étudie tous les tous les cas de
figure
l'organisation l'OCS a été bâti en
contrepoids à influence
occidentale il y a eu donc ces
déclarations les a entendues de Vladimir
Poutine de jijin ping cette forme de
front uni face à l'Occident mais tous
les pays de cette organisation Adrien
besoins ils ne sont pas forcément
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit par
Vladimir Poutine et Gigi ping je pense
au Kazakhstan par exemple oui il y a une
forme d'inquiétude même parfois une
forme de solidarité avec ce qui est en
train de vivre l'Ukraine pour les pays
comme le Kazakhstan ou certains
nationalistes russes disent bon après
tout ce qu'on a fait en Ukraine on
pourrait troupes très bien le faire
aussi au Kazakhstan et pour revenir à
l'OCS c'est elle a réussi à parler des
tas artificiel à en parler
Kazakhstan donc ça pourrait être le
prochain sur la liste voilà bon on verra
bien en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est en
2001 quand la l'OCS a été créé c'était
pas j'allais dire une organisation qui
était fait en opposition à l'Occident
c'est une forme de G7 j'allais dire
oreiller eurasiatique si vous voulez
mais c'est vrai que pour la Chine qui
est un empire commercial avant tout
avant d'être un empire militaire comme
la pu l'être la Russie il est plus
important de disposer d'un interlan ou
c'est à dire d'une d'un endroit
possibilité de contourner les océans et
de pouvoir écouler ces marchandises par
les fameuses routes de la soie et
d'ailleurs le sommet là il a lieu à sa
marque qui est vraiment le le la ville
j'allais dire emblématique de ces de ces
routes de la soie donc il y a une forme
aussi de symbolique de relance peut-être
de la Chine de de pouvoir continuer à
écouler ces produits
sans peut-être passer par la Russie mais
en passant par l'Asie centrale j'ai vu
aussi que le président turc était invité
était là donc c'est pas anodin aussi que
jimping ait choisi l'Asie centrale pour
son premier déplacement depuis deux ans
vous vouliez réagir Pierre Antoine Denet
en ce qui concerne les Kazakhstan il y a
un aspect aussi qui est important pour
la Chine parce que le Kazakhstan est
frontalié du Cynthia et donc avec la
crise des wigoux le soutien du
Kazakhstan pour endiguer tout ce qui
partent est important pour la Chine mais
dans je voudrais parler du contexte dans
lequel la Chine se trouvait après
l'invasion le 24 février par la Russie
de l'Ukraine
en même temps ils n'ont jamais non plus
ouvertement soutenu alors je voulais
juste encore un peu élargir tout ça
l'image parce que
l'Ukraine immédiatement on parle de
Taïwan et
regarde de très près
et d'ailleurs je rentre de taïwanais
j'ai passé deux semaines et bien
évidemment si inping sont l'équipe quand
ils ont vu cette guerre qui s'est
déclarait ont-ils été informé ou pas
avant on sera peut-être jamais mais en
tout cas le fait que ça tourne mal
aujourd'hui c'est riche d'enseignement
pour aussi dingping vis-à-vis de Taïwan
et je voudrais rajouter que Taïwan et
l'Ukraine c'est totalement différent
parce que l'Ukraine est frontalière de
la Russie de façon terrestre alors que
Taïwan c'est une île qui au plus près
est à 130 km des côtes chinoises du
continent chinois l'Armée populaire de
libération n'a aucune expérience de
débarquement en guerre en mer donc
envahir Taïwan serait infiniment plus
compliqué et le coup humain serait
énorme
la Chine elle joue à un jeu
d'équilibriste depuis le la guerre en
Ukraine
je pense et encore une fois chez du mal
à rajouter quoi que ce soit à toutes les
analyses que je viens d'entendre et qui
qui ont tout dit sur le sujet mais
encore une fois je voudrais répéter un
thème qui m'est qui m'est important
c'est que la Chine aussi en jouant les
équilibristes peut aussi jouer un rôle
de médiateur d'arbitre et c'est ce
qu'elle a fait par exemple pour la Corée
du Nord c'est c'est c'est également pour
un état tout énorme diplomatique pour la
Chine c'est la capacité à calmer le jeu
du côté du gouvernement nord-coréen et
là aussi elle aurait vu qu'il y a une
effectivement une interdépendance je
crois que quand même la Russie dépend
beaucoup plus de de la Chine que
l'inverse la Chine peut également
contrôler la Russie calmer les ardeurs
de de Poutine ou ou d'un succès et et
jouer encore une fois des arbitres ça ça
peut être ils peuvent jouer un rôle
crucial en effet si soudain
Poutine disparaît ou si comme comment
le spécule depuis depuis quelques jours
s'il y a une révolution de palais par
exemple un petit coup d'état ou un
changement de régime ou certainement pas
une révolution mais le changement
d'origine est sur
la non je ne pense pas je ne pense pas
parce que si si un changement ça sera
pas un changement je devrais dire plutôt
pas un changement de régime mais un
changement de gouvernement ça serait si
ce n'est pas la mort de Poutine qu'on
dit malade mais on en est pas sûr il
peut y avoir effectivement
des des factions qui prennent le pouvoir
et qui qui font de Poutine ce qu'on a
fait de de rouge pioche autrefois et
dans ce cas l'Occident ne sachant pas
sur sur quel pied danser ne sachant pas
acquises auront à faire et bien pourront
s'appuyer finalement sur la Chine pour
pour essayer d'établir un dialogue s'il
y a encore possibilité de de dialogue la
Chine Pierre-Antoine Denet qui peut pas
aller trop loin de toute façon dans son
soutien à Moscou la Chine elle a besoin
aujourd'hui
désoxydants dans le cadre de la
mondialisation c'est impossible pour
elle de se mettre tout l'Occident à dos
[Musique]
surtout non là il montre qu'il va il va
en Ouzbékistan et que la vie continue
donc il a l'air assez sûr de lui quand
même
Sylvie Berman est-ce que la ce qui se
passe en ce moment sur le terrain en
Ukraine cette débâcle russe ça pourrait
ébranler ce partenariat chinois sinon
russe non je ne crois pas parce que
encore une fois ils ont un intérêt
mutuel
qui est de lutter contre ce qu'il
considère l'un comme l'autre des
provocations des États-Unis voire de
l'OTAN puisque lors du dernier sommet de
l'OTAN il y a une petite phrase qui a
été insérée sur la Chine devenant une
menace systémique et en tout cas les
deux pays
déclarent qu'il faut considérer les
intérêts de sécurité pour la Chine de la
Russie les Chinois le disent très
clairement et à tous les niveaux et pour
les Russes de la Chine sur Taïwan et à
l'occasion cette rencontre Vladimir
Poutine a encore condamné les
provocations américaines à Taïwan donc
je ne pense pas que ça changera moi je
ne crois pas une révolution de palais
parce que il est quand même extrêmement
protégé et même s'il y a des désaccords
et très probablement y compris au sein
de l'armée je ne pense pas que c'est
possible je pourrais toujours être
démenti bien sûr on ne prévoit jamais
ce type de révolution mais ce que disent
tous les Russes qui s'opposent à la
guerre c'est que si quelqu'un prenait
cette initiative ce sera certainement
pas un grand démocrate et il risque
quand même peut-être d'être pire que lui
et faut pas oublier qu'il y a de l'autre
côté c'est on a vu certaines maisons
pas
les révolutions révolution de palais
coup d'État non vous savez les
besoin et simping en particulier et tu
dis depuis des années
la dislocation de l'Union soviétique et
font tout pour l'éviter ils détestent
Gorbatchev et je pense que c'est
évidemment ça ne leur plaît pas du tout
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque tout de
même si la Russie ça faiblit dans cette
guerre en
Ukraine que ça recentre l'attention des
États-Unis sur Taïwan Taïwan dont on
parlait tout à l'heure parce que là
aussi je pense que la direction chinoise
le Parti communiste chinois a étudié de
très près la réaction de l'Occident
après l'invasion de l'Ukraine et là je
dois dire que
jusqu'à un certain point bien sûr
Poutine n'a totalement
manqué de vision et surtout il
s'attendait pas du tout à la réaction
qu'il y a eu bon pour résumer l'OTAN
dont le président Macron disait encore
l'an dernier qu'il était en très mal il
n'est jamais plus vivant qu'aujourd'hui
l'Union européenne qui avait beaucoup de
difficultés à continuer sa marche vers
l'Union et bien elle a réussi en
l'espace de moins ce qu'elle n'a pas
réussi à faire en disant ensuite au-delà
de ça
cette mobilisation
occidentale sur les graines et bien pour
Taïwan elle va se répliquer à peu près
de la même manière en tout cas venant
des États-Unis c'est une certitude on va
écouter juste encore une phrase les
États-Unis ne sont pas seuls parce qu'on
voit bien que tous les pays riverains de
la Chine commencent à bouger à commencer
par le Japon le Japon qui s'inquiète
mais plus que ça le Japon qui a une
constitution qui lui a été imposée par
les Américains en 48 qui interdit au
Japon d'intervenir militairement sur un
théâtre étranger et bien le premier à en
parler c'était shinzoa B qui a été
assassiné par par un dingo
mais tout ça s'est repris par le Premier
ministre qui est en exercice
le Congrès américain il a voté hier une
première aide directe de Washington à
Taïwan un vote qui a été dénoncé
aujourd'hui par Pékin on va écouter tout
de suite
concernant l'entretien que j'ai eu avec
le président russe malheureusement je ne
peux pas vous dire qu'il y a maintenant
une prise de conscience croissante que
c'était une erreur de commencer cette
guerre et rien ne laisse à penser qu'une
nouvelle position est en train d'émerger
là-bas
la Chine observe de presse qui se passe
en Ukraine on en a beaucoup parlé
est-ce que avec ce qui se passe sur le
terrain je vous repose la question elle
peut craindre que les États-Unis
ressentent finalement leur attention sur
sur Taïwan
il y a peut-être une possibilité que la
que la Chine calme les ardeurs de
Poutine alors je voudrais rassurer
madame Berman que je que je salue au
passage je ne crois pas non plus une
révolution de palais preuve en est
regardez l'enregistrement de notre débat
sur ce même plateau il y a il y a 48
heures je donne 10% de chances
nécessaires purement rhétorique
révolution de palais autre chose peu
importe je répète l'important c'est que
la Chine peut être en position et c'est
son atout principal
pour arbitrer une solution éventuelle en
espérant qu'il y a qu'il y a une
solution ce qui n'est ce qui n'est pour
le moment pas encore évident
il est évident que cette
cette cette agression contre l'Ukraine
n'arrange pas du tout la Chine a aucun
intérêt direct mais voir indirect à
ce genre de stratégie
tout à l'heure on disait que Poutine est
trop sûr de lui et sûr de lui très sûr
de lui oui mais c'est ça tout le
problème c'est que
ça commence à rappeler un peu les les
dirigeants en nord-coréen et sud-coréen
pendant la pendant la guerre de Corée
dans les années 50
qui qui embarrassait même Staline
Staline n'était pas absolument
enthousiaste par cette guerre parce que
ça pose énormément de problèmes il y a
énormément de problèmes à gérer ça
déstabilise tout simplement et en effet
ça déstabilise toutes les relations qui
étaient quand même très équilibrées dans
toutes toutes les os autour de la Chine
et en nous parlant de la Corée du Sud
nous parons parlons du Japon comme s'il
a été dit tout à l'heure et d'autres
voisins également de les tous les pays
de l'azéanes
la Russie tout à l'heure à 10 soutenir
toute action possible de la Chine à
Taïwan est-ce que ce soutient russe est
important pour Pékin c'est un soutien
oui c'est un soutien important parce que
la Russie est quand même en permanence
du Conseil de sécurité c'est un voisin
et c'est un de la région puisque la
Russie était aussi une puissance
asiatique donc évidemment c'est
important mais
revenir sur votre question sur les
Américains qui seraient entre guillemets
gênés parce que
il doit devoir être intervenir sur deux
fonds à Taïwan et en Ukraine etc je
pense pas que ce soit un vrai problème
parce que les États-Unis c'est une
puissance globale et en fait ils ont ils
ont en mesure d'intervenir partout en
même temps et surtout en début de la
guerre en Ukraine ils ont ils ont changé
un peu leur leur vision ils sont ils ont
ils sont recentrés un peu sur l'Europe
sur ce qui se passait en Ukraine et on
laissait un peu tomber comme pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale si vous aviez
toute une partie de l'armée américaine
qui est battait dans le Pacifique une
partie qui se battait en Europe et les
États-Unis sont capables de se battre
des deux côtés à la fois donc je pense
pas que ce soit un problème sachant
quand même que les États-Unis de leur
priorité restera toujours le Pacifique
c'est pour eux c'est l'essentiel sont
des traumatisés par Hawaï etc pour
revenir sur le Japon je voulais juste
remarquer mais peut-être que vous me
contredirez que le les Japonais ont été
plus mesurés que les Européens sur tout
ce qui était sanctions
parce que ils sont peut-être plus
indépendant au plus fragile
avait d'excellentes relations avec
Poutine il se voyait pratiquement tous
les deux mois c'est-à-dire que ce que
espérait shinzoa B c'est obtenir la
restitution des courriers ou d'une
partie des courrilles ce qu'il n'a
jamais eu mais leur relation personnelle
en tout cas étaient excellente ce qui
explique peut-être aujourd'hui une
certaine prudence du du Japon j'aimerais
qu'on vienne sur le jeu de la Chine avec
Moscou est-ce que la Chine finalement
elle ne joue pas un double jeu
aujourd'hui on a parlé tout à l'heure
des routes de la soie elle essaie
d'étendre un peu son influence en Asie
centrale et en même temps elle soutient
la Russie la Russie qui est qui a sa
zone d'influence en agit centrale
aujourd'hui
plusieurs pions à la fois c'est comme le
jeu de gauche c'est un peu cliché de
dire ça mais
voilà ils peuvent aussi intervenir de
façon c'est pas un joueur d'échec comme
souvent on compare Poutine c'est
vraiment un jeu de de d'ancerclement de
de lignes
donc non je je suis pas très surpris par
parce que fait Gigi parce que jijing
ping effectivement son économie vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et très
dépendant de l'économie américaine donc
elle peut pas se permettre de trop
soutenir la Russie parce que sinon elle
s'exposerait à des sanctions économiques
qui affaibliraient son économie et qui
près de covid il reste quand même un peu
fragile on va écouter tout de suite JJ
ping hier au Kazakhstan où il a assuré
se porter garant de l'intégrité
territoriale du pays
le Kazakhstan est un pays majeur en Asie
centrale et à une influence importante
en Asie je tiens à réitérer le fait que
le gouvernement chinois attache une
grande importance à sa relation avec le
Kazakhstan quel que soit l'évolution de
la situation internationale la Chine
soutiendra toujours fermement le
Kazakhstan dans la sauvegarde de
l'indépendance nationale et de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale
Pékin soutient les régimes autoritaires
quand il y a eu ces centaines de morts
dans les rues au 15 accents de la
capitale du Kazakhs
ils ont raison il fallait tuer dans
l'oeuvre cette contestation et c'est la
position invariable du Parti communiste
chinois depuis 1949 et elle s'est
accentuée avec six INPI alors maintenant
pour revenir à Taïwan
vous savez là aussi la Chine a montré
où s'arrête ses capacités militaires
quand Nancy Pelosi a visité Taïwan elle
est restée 24 heures mais c'était très
lourd de signification parce qu'elle est
la numéro 3 en fait du pouvoir aux
États-Unis et bien évidemment en Chine
dans cette visite oui exactement mais
bon c'est tout à fait naturel on
attendait pas que qui se félicite de la
visite de Madame Pelosi à Taipei bien
sûr et donc ils ont déclenché toute une
série de manœuvres militaires navales et
aérienne sans précédent d'ailleurs
depuis 1949 d'ailleurs et bien qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé un à Taïwan une sérénité
totale
pas de panique dans les rues rien au
contraire ils sont habitués vous savez
et eux aussi ils n'ont pas perdu du
temps ça fait très longtemps qui
s'attendent à une invasion chinoise à
Taïwan ici prépare et je peux vous dire
pendant mon séjour à talon j'ai
rencontré quelques experts taïwanais des
questions militaires et je vous assure
ils sont prêts à résister le temps
suffisant pour que la septième flotte et
tout l'Armada américain soit là ça veut
dire une semaine s'il le faut et même
plus ils ont mis au point ce qui
s'appelle une guerre asymétrique ça
coûterait extrêmement cher à la Chine
populaire en termes de pertes humaines
et il faut savoir que quoi on verrait
des Chinois qui sont entrent les uns les
autres mais il y a une différence
majeure c'est que en Chine avec la
politique de l'enfant unique qui
maintenant a été abandonnée mais trop
tard
on verrait quoi des soldats chinois qui
se fraient être suicider sur le théâtre
taïwanais ces familles qui n'ont qu'un
fils qu'est-ce qui dirait alors
évidemment toute cette population elle
était étroitement contrôlée mais je vous
assure que les dégâts seraient énormes
apparaît réaliste un conflit à Taïwan on
sait aujourd'hui que en plus Gigi en
tout ce qui fait sur la scène
internationale c'est en vue du Congrès
du Parti communiste chinois qui aura
lieu en novembre oui mais je pense que
les Chinois voient plus long terme en
tout cas je pense pas qu'il y a un
conflit à Taïwan soit prévisible à court
terme profitant de la guerre en Ukraine
si vous laissez pas je pense pas du tout
que ce soit l'hypothèse de chez INPI eux
leur objectif c'est 2049 c'est le
centenaire du Parti communiste chinois
c'est l'objectif qui se sont fixés pour
réunir la Chine et Taïwan donc ça laisse
encore un peu de temps mais à mon avis
ça risque d'être un peu juste quand même
oui enfin si inking a dit aussi que
c'était sa mission historique donc là il
va être prolongé de 5 ans de 10 ans on
ne sait pas mais je suis d'accord avec
vous pour le moment il n'en est pas
question ce qui explique aussi le calme
des taïwanais cela dit cette visite a
quand même permis au chinois de faire un
exercice en grandeur réel sans susciter
beaucoup de réactions ce qu'il n'aurait
pas pu faire autrement quant à
l'intervention des Américains il faut se
rappeler que en Ukraine ils sont très
très actifs en matière de renseignement
comment on dit et justement
ils interviendrait de d'une autre
manière c'est-à-dire en engageant le
conflit avec la Chine deux puissances
est-ce que ça serait possible moi je
suis assez sceptique et puis ça dépend
qui est au pouvoir aussi aux États-Unis
parce que Trump était évidemment très
hostile à la Chine mais en même temps un
jour il avait montré assez généraux le
globe en disant ben regarder où est la
Chine regardez au Taïwan et regardez où
nous sommes il avait conclu nous
n'interviendrons pas donc tout ça n'est
évidemment pas définitif personne ne
sait ce qui se passerait mais il y aura
une aide américaine c'est très clair
est-ce qu'elle dépassera ce qu'elle a
été en Ukraine ce n'est pas sûr oh les
cocktail vous vouliez réagir
encore une fois je suis toute fait
d'accord avec Madame Berman qui qui
m'enlève les les paroles de la bouche
une remarque une remarque à propos de ce
qu'a dit Monsieur Denain tout ce qu'il a
dit sur Taïwan
fait peut-être réfléchir en effet Pékin
Pékin sera beaucoup plus prudent je ne
veux pas éliminer non plus le risque
qu'ils envahissent effectivement bon
Taiwan en profitant de l'Ukraine et
d'après cette préparation taïwanaise à
une catastrophe de ce type je pense que
Pékin s'en rend compte et justement
peut-être c'est pour ça qu'il y aura
moins de chance d'une intervention
pékinoise communiste à Taiwan mais ça
montre également le déséquilibre entre
la diplomatie russe et la diplomatie
chinoise la capacité en fait de la
Russie du Kremlin à comprendre des
grandes situations
géo stratégiques
c'est exactement ce qu'aurait dû prévoir
Poutine il aurait dû prévoir la
résistance ukrainienne or on voit qu'il
est tombé véritablement dans un piège je
dis pas que qui n'écrasera pas un jour
l'Ukraine j'espère que non mais de toute
manière pas du tout prévu cette
résistance il s'imaginait que que les
chars les chats russes défileraient à
Kiev au bout de au bout de cinq ou six
jours donc ça monte encore une fois
qu'il y a quand même une une
inégalité entre
le renseignement le
et tout simplement la prévision et
l'analyse d'une situation géopolitique à
Moscou qui prend en fait souvent ses
désirs pour les réalités alors que je
pense que cap Pékin ils sont beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus les pieds sur terre
beaucoup plus réalistes et du coup
capable d'exercer encore une fois je
vais le répéter encore et encore exercer
une influence sur la Russie
Adrien 2 juin
sur qui aujourd'hui la Chine peut
compter outre la Russie
en cas de conflit à Taïwan ah en cas de
conflit avec Taïwan ah oui alors là
c'est une question plus difficile
sans doute un soutien nord-coréen sans
doute quelques alliés peut-être la
Birmanie j'en sais rien
pas grand monde en réalité
c'est difficile de faire de la Russie
aujourd'hui à la Chine elle a beaucoup
d'alliés économique finalement
militairement qui qui a envie d'aider la
Chine à s'affronter contre les
États-Unis honnêtement personne parce
que personne n'a intéresse à se mettre
au milieu de ce truc là ce serait de la
folie pure donc non je pense que
là où les chinois sont peut-être un peu
présomptueux c'est de penser qu'il y a
un jour les Taïwanais voudront vraiment
se réunir à la Chine alors que plus les
années passent et plus les Taïwanais
s'écartent de la Chine et ont moins en
moins envie
[Musique]
non mais il y aurait pas d'intervention
militaires
à la Chine mais ils sont en train de
construire un appareil très puissant et
rapidement mais en revanche et le
contraire sur probablement les pays
d'Afrique d'Amérique latine tous ces
pays qu'ils ont cultivé depuis des
années et que la Russie cultive aussi
donc on se retrouverait un peu dans
cette dans cette même situation merci
beaucoup merci à tous les quatre merci
Pierre-Antoine Denet merci Sylvie Berman
merci Adrien dezur merci collègue kope
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur France
24 restez avec nous l'information
continue
[Musique]